i've heard you have had
dwindlings or little
rumors of a presidential run
no
no no chance no chance none
none how could you put your kids through
that i could never put my children
through all the grief that that happens
in a political campaign just not going
to happen now i actually considered it
at one point and we had a family vote
we did have a family vote so i'm not
crazy well i mean i know i am but
you thought about it was five in our
family and the vote was four to one with
i was the only yes and so
yeah i mean the family doesn't agree
just can't happen
i totally appreciate that that's why
you'd make such a great president
okay well
um now i was curious i was watching
inventing anna oh i love that show it's
just insane
i mean it's just the craziest thing ever
how does one pull off getting people to
invest and convince who is a complete
fraud how
do we svengali our way into this what do
you see when you see a show like that
she made one big mistake you can't steal
that's the one thing you can't do you
can fake it till you make it but when
she was ripping off the hotels when she
would refuse to pay back um the credit
card for her friend
that if she had not done that
she would ended up being in a great spot
because even though she didn't get her
281 park or whatever it was and she
didn't create our club and whether or
not that was a good idea i don't know
but everything else she did was just
networking and learning and putting
yourself in a position to succeed and if
she just had not ripped people off
we she'd be having conversations with
those same people saying you know what
that first thing you know the club
didn't work but let's talk about this
and she'd have great relationships with
them
but when you try to steal when you
actually steal from somebody
you go to jail and that's exactly what
she deserved and the karmic ladder you
cannot climb cannot climb that ladder
right the karma you know
payback's a [ __ ] and she's getting she
faced it
um well i mean you are a favorite shark
everybody loves you on that show it's so
fun to watch you you learn you get
excited
but gosh if i have this opportunity to
ask what is one of your favorite gets
on shark tank and what is the one that
got away
the one that got away was oh my goodness
um spike ball people on the beach are
always playing thrown out it's great
exercise and they wanted to create a
league a spike ball league and have me
be the commissioner
i did not want to be the commissioner of
the spike ball league so that one got
away and they just blew up one that i
got that i'm really proud of was a
company called cycloramic and what they
did was back when the iphone 5 was out
they had an app that when you put it on
a flat surface and started it it would
take these panoramic pictures and i just
thought that was really cool it became
the number one app in in the um app
store when the shark tank aired and then
iphone changed what it looked like so
you couldn't just stand it up so these
guys had to pivot and they pivoted into
something called computer vision
software and they turned into this huge
enormous success um speaking of apps i
was watching uh super pumped oh you the
battle for uber starring joseph
gordon-levitt everybody get ready for
your next favorite show by the way it's
so good yep super pump is great
you're in it yeah i made my little
appearance yes yeah is it true that you
had anything to do with uber at one
point or were considering it and then so
travis the guy who started uber travis
kalanick kalanick yeah so he had a
company red swoosh that i invested in
then he comes to me with uber and i was
one of the very first people it was
called uber cab and travis and i had
this love hate relationship and so i'm
like travis i love the idea but you're
going to have all these problems
you're not raising enough money
and i went shark tank on them and
didn't like the valuation and he was
like fine and never called me back so i
had a chance to be one of the very first
investors in uber and i missed it okay
so there is a potential guy uh here who
might be a shark tank uh material would
you be so kind
as to um after the break come and um
meet him with me and see what his
invention is for you drew i'll do
anything including run for president one
day with me almost anything
all right we'll be right back
[Music]
you